كل ثاني يوم أذهب إلى الساونا ، أذهب إلى
الساونا مرة أو مرتين في الأسبوع ، أحاول أن أفعل
ذلك ، لا أستحم كل يوم ، لدي حسنًا بالنسبة
للبعض منا ، سأرى نوعًا فرعيًا من الأشجار
أربع مرات في الأسبوع في معظم
أنحاء  تعتبر حمامات الساونا العالمية رفاهية ،
ولكن في بعض أجزاء لابلاند ، تكون المنطقة
التي تمتد عبر شمال أوروبا
شائعة مثل علامات الشوارع ، حيث
يمكنك العثور على ساونا في أي مكان
مثل هذه المدينة الصغيرة أو في
الفناء الخلفي لهذا الشخص أو في
منتصف  الغابة أو حتى بالقرب من نهر
[موسيقى]
لدينا مناخ بارد ، لذا من الجيد
أن تحصل على شيء دافئ للدخول إليه ، فأنا أشعر
بالدفء إلى العظام ، فإن
ثقافة الساونا هنا هي حقًا فريدة من نوعها حقًا
إذا قمت ببناء منزل جديد تبدأ به
ساونا وتقوم ببناء منزل
حول حمامات الساونا ، حيث يوجد عدد أكبر من الساونا
للفرد الواحد في أي مكان آخر في
العالم ، يوجد مليوني ساونا هنا أو
حوالي واحدة لكل أسرة ولكن بعض المنازل
بها أكثر من ذلك وفي هذه
المنطقة لا يوجد الناس '  ر مجرد بناء
منزل  حول حمامات الساونا ، يوجد حتى
أكاديمية ساونا ومتحف ساونا هنا في
ثقافتنا ، كانت الساونا غرفة نظيفة
مكانًا جيدًا لولادة الأطفال ،
الأصوات الأولى التي حصلنا عليها من
1200 قرن عندما أصيبنا بالأنفلونزا
وستشعر  ليس جيدًا ، لقد قالوا دائمًا ،
اذهب إلى الصوت ، قال الناس إنه لطيف جدًا
صيدلية الرجل الفقير ، أقسم أن الصوت القديم
سوف يسخن الحجر عندما
تتأذى الحجارة ، يمكنك وضع الماء على
الحجارة ثم يأتي البخار اللطيف بالنسبة
لي  عملية الساونا مثل الضلع الصغير
يجب أن تكون مثل لعبة كرة القدم على الأقل
فترتين ثلاث مرات لذلك تبدأ في الذهاب
إلى الساونا والحصول على بعض الحرارة والخروج إلى
الخارج واستنشاق بعض الهواء النقي ربما تتدحرج
في الثلج ثم تذهب إلى غرفة مريحة
تأكل شيئًا  والجلوس والتحدث
هناك وقتًا لفترة
ثانية وتناول الشراب مرة أخرى وما إلى ذلك ، يجب أن
تأخذ وقتك في الساونا
ولكن هذا ليس كل شيء في حمامات البخار في لابلاند
تستخدم كدليل على حسن الضيافة
ولمناقشة الأمور السياسية ، فهناك
شيء يسمى الساونا  دبلوماسي لأن
لدينا الكثير من حمامات الساونا ، نقوم ببعض
التحدث ومناقشة المشاكل
وقررنا كيفية المضي قدمًا ، استخدمت فنلندا
الدبلوماسية الصوتية ، وأنقذ الرئيس
فنلندا من روسيا ، كما تعلم ، فقد
خلع ملابس الجنرالات الروس
وأخذهم في صدى.  كان رجلان
يتحدثان مع بعضهما البعض ، لم يكن هناك أي
ميداليات أو أي شيء يجلسان هناك
يتحدثان ، لذا لا توجد دبلوماسية أنت
[موسيقى]
تعرف أن هذا لطيف جدًا مثل الحدث ، إنه
المكان الذي تجري فيه المناقشات
حول شؤون الأسرة إذا حدث
شيء تحدثنا عنه
إذا لم يكن
لديك ساونا ، فما الذي يجب أن تفعله إذا
لم يكن لدي ساونا ،
يفكر البعض في أنني لا أعرف جيدًا
لا أعرف
[موسيقى]